AY BY THE
GOALTENDER STOLARZ.
AND BACK THE OTHER WAY.
THE AS TWOCOMTOIS. UP AND DOWN .
LOT OF SKILL IN
HUGHES ON THE PUCK WILL FROM AL.
HE HAD 5 5SHOT.
TROY TERRY TO OPEN THE SCORING.
MARGIN IN THAT CATEGORY.
AND ALL HE DOES IS STEP UP
INSIDE THE BLUE LINE. ON
2-0.
HERE IS A BREAK-AWAY AS GRAVES
GETS
OR -- CLAUDE IT IN.
BACK THE OTHER WAY.
BOQVIST FOR THE DEVILS.S.  TO T.
PICKS UP THAT PUPU THE LOOSE
PUCK AND HE'LL PLAY IT AHEAD.
MERCER PICKS UP
THIRD.
HEADLINE EVENT TONIGHT WAS
HUGHES VERSUS THE
SIDE OF --
>> Ken TO GET IT
STARTED.
CAM FOWLER GOOD CHANCES
COME TO THE DUCKS IN OVERTIME
HERE.
WATCH BENCH.
JACK HUGHES WALKING ES AT THE C
FIRED WIDE.
TRYING TO HOLD THE ZONE.
HAMILTLT JACK
HUGHES.
NICE KEEP-IN BY DOUGIE HAMILTON
AFTER THE DEVILS MISSED THE
FIRST OPPORTUNITY GET
SOMETHING ARE DESPERATE THE
DEVILS ARE PLAYING.
>> Steve: TATAR IN ROUND ONE.NC.
HE CAME IN QUICKLY
MOVING IN QUICKLY ON DAWS. SHOO.
MOVING IN THAT IS VINTAGE